right here in the lobby of Ramsey
solutions a couple of heroes that are
debt-free because they worked their
butts off and they use their brains way
to go you guys how much debt of you guys
paid off
we paid off thirty five thousand nine
hundred and seventeen dollars I love it
and this is Josh and Tracy and you guys
are from where Nashville Tennessee
Nashville right here so your neighbors
then very cool how long did it take you
to pay off your thirty six thousand six
months six months very good and making a
range of income of what around 45,000
around forty five K what do you guys do
for a living we're ministry okay very
cool with which church well we are you
have a non-profit or it's like a
nonprofit yeah we kind of reach into
people groups that are unreached and uh
sure about the love of Jesus that people
here in Nashville very cool any
particular people groups there's a whole
group of people groups we on southeast
Nashville there's a whole whole group of
people groups there definitely it's
become international yes a lot of Nepal
there a lot of other things yeah very
cool good for you guys that's very neat
and so what kind of debt was the thirty
six thousand it was IRS debts credit
cards and student loan and a car ah Wow
so what I mean you did not make enough
to feed your family in six months and
pay off thirty six thousand so what you
do we sold the car and oh how much of
this was car I know it was about
eighteen thousand half of it yes there
okay yeah it needed to go good okay what
are you driving we're driving now yeah
in 2006 Toyota Sienna oh not bad okay
very good when it's paid for obviously
yes okay cool so you've sold the car
what else did you do to get out of that
really we just saw God provided you know
Abraham when he leaves his dad he
believes that I God who brings things
into existence that don't exist we saw
that same thing constantly we saw a God
provide when we had no idea how how we
can see give me give me an example
yeah I mean we we went to the smart
money conference last October the funks
and your team members yeah took us yeah
and then we started financial peace with
them and after that we just started
we were written budget and then I really
don't want to sell my van yeah
and I kept asking about so my van and
you kept saying steal the car so we sold
the car and we just trusted and so about
in January
once we sold the van we just started
seeing God provides us through various
family members or ministry partners that
we have they were just not knowing that
we needed money they just God would
provide through sending a check in the
mail through a little bit of inheritance
that we got cool yes sir and then just
got the ball rolling and then just
continued just to watch God so these
unexpected checks that come in from
ministry partners from inheritance from
different things that's just God winking
at you going you on the right track
amazing you're just doing you're just
doing the good thing so we're gonna
these two are smart let's give them a
little more when you're faithful in the
little you'll be given more to manage
and scriptural okay good for you - very
very well done I'm very proud of you how
does it feel awesome just to be freedom
to do what God has called us to do and
not have to worry about finances um
anymore so it's awesome okay now I get
the part that God played where he sent
you and he was gracious and he provided
what did you do that was faithful where
were you trustworthy on how you were
getting out of that what was what do you
tell people the keys to getting out of
debt are and I think for us especially
it was being on the same page like when
John funk asked us to go to the smart
money live I was like oh you can go and
I'll keep the kids we don't can't get a
babysitter and and then God provided for
us to get a babysitter and so we got a
babysitter we both were able to go and
it was just being on the same page that
was huge for us like we're both headed
in the same direction for the same
purpose we were in tents like we were
like nothing's in our way we were
getting out of debt in our original like
protection to get out of debt was like
18 months yeah I was like oh that's a
long time and then I mean we just yeah
we get getting around the car
accelerated that you didn't after God
list of the car it was good
very cool congratulations thanks very
very proud of you
and you have how many kids we have 33
kids yes three three mm-hmm
okay Emma Kate Eli and Ellie yes right
okay we'll bring them over
have they been practicing their debt
free screen yeah okay so they're ready
to do this and how old are they
Emma Kate's 10 Eli seven and Ellie's
five all right very very cool
all right we've got a copy of Chris
Hogan's book retire inspired for you
signed by him because that's your next
step is continue to build wealth and
that'll put you in a position to
continue to do ministry I think it's
very cool stuff and continue the
generous living that you obviously have
as a whole lifestyle for you guys so
very very proud of him glad we were able
to walk with you I'm glad John and them
had you come over and be part of it and
it's very very neat very proud of you
guys see folks people can be smart they
can be smart they can make decisions
these two did it man way to go all right
Josh and Tracy Emma Kate Eli and Ellie
$36,000 paid off in six months making
forty five thousand that includes the
sale of an $18,000 van count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three
go you guys that is awesome way to go so
you can do this but you got to decide
you got to look at your life and here's
the thing when you start looking at the
ratios in your life you know you know
what stupid looks like you you sit down
you look you go look you know we got
$30,000 in car debt and we make 40,000
well that's stupid and you know you
don't have you don't need me to tell you
that you can look at it and go of course
that's stupid
no wonder I can't breathe this car owns
me I don't own it the borrower is slave
to the lender personal finance is 80%
behavior it's only 20% head knowledge
you can make decisions but you just have
stop and sort of thinking and quit
impulsing like you're 4 years old and as
soon as you do that I see people listen
hey if you ever gone on a trip and you
look up and you're before GPS maybe
maybe some of you have been on trip
before GPS you're not that old but you
look up and you're going the wrong way
and you're going 70 miles an hour down
the interstate the wrong way when you go
out we're in the wrong way we do you get
off the exit right you go onto the
bridge you turn left back up onto the
ramp and you jump back up on going back
the way you should have been going in
the first place and you're back up 70
miles an hour now you are not heading 70
miles an hour towards your direction
towards your destination technically you
are but you need to understand you've
just changed your velocity not by 70 but
by 70 plus 70 because you were going 70
miles an hour in the wrong direction
now you're going 70 miles an hour in the
right direction that's a hundred and
forty miles an hour change and that's
what happens when you make a u-turn with
any area of your life you don't just
make the progress in the direction you
should have been going in the first
place you also are no longer heading in
the wrong direction at breakneck speed
so when you cut up the credit cards and
quit borrowing money you have plastic
surgery and quit borrowing money when
you say we're not borrowing money on a
car anymore
we're never going on vacation unless we
pay cash for it again when you get ready
to go to college
baby oh you're going to a college we can
write a check for and you're gonna get a
scholarship and a job and when you start
making decisions like that and you start
putting this value system over your
family you've not just you've quit going
in the hole at the rate of tens of
thousands of dollars and now you're not
only not going in the hole you're
digging out of the hole at the rate of
tens of thousands of dollars so this is
20s of 40s of 50s of hundreds of
thousands of dollars now in the right
direction and it turns into millions
when you start investing it the reason
people are broke in America is not
because they don't have enough income
it's not because they have this problem
or that problem it's cuz if we can spend
everything that's why they're broke
because they don't have their life under
control so get yourself on a written
plan go to every dollar calm it's free
shut up it's free for your Android your
iPhone get your every dollar budget
going where your turn telling every
dollar what to do every month and you
know people are paying off that like
crazy when you start doing this stuff on
purpose it clears your debt it changes
everything what you gotta do it on
purpose
no one wanders out of that you could
wander into debt no one wakes up a
millionaire accidentally unless they hit
you know unless they hit the lottery
which would be a freaking accident or
unless they inherited it but
eighty-eight percent of America's
millionaires nine out of ten
millionaires are first-generation rich
they started with nothing and they
didn't accidentally go Oh came from no
they systematically saved and invested
by staying out of debt and staying on a
plan and using something like every
dollar to do it this works this works
this is not a game since your life this
is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show
now